with me right now is somebody that wrote
on a topic that every single home
listening to me right now
uh has something they can relate to
about it his name is uh greg zuckerman
he's not new to our show
greg's got a brand new book out and i
think the first time greg you came on it
was about the wildcatters uh the
frackers yes right and what they did and
we that's still an apt topic your brand
new book out today is called a shot to
save the world the inside story of the
life or death race for a covid19 vaccine
you do not take on easy topics would you
take on very important topics i try to
explain how big things happened uh for
you know the average reader because i'm
sort of an average guy and there's often
a lot of drama that people aren't aware
of and also
innovation and entrepreneurship and i
think we need to appreciate it 2019
happens we don't even know how china
gave us this virus we don't know we
thought we have some strange animal bat
theory and we got the more likely theory
now the wuhan lab theory but all we know
is americans are getting it there's
asymptomatic spread this person to
person spread we don't even know exactly
what we're dealing with but we know we
got to stop it
where does your book pick up yes so i
tell the drama of the past year but i
first start decades earlier why do i do
that because the approaches that we
have depended on for these vaccines mrna
this adenovirus one that led to the jng
and some other ones these approaches
actually they started years earlier all
in america we're talking about
innovators researchers scientists in
labs just slogging away
trying to push it forward
meeting frustrations and i want to shed
light on how it was a long process so
some of us are nervous and for good
reason well all of a sudden we've got
these vaccines and we in the average
vaccine until this year
10 years it takes the average vaccine
the fastest one ever was measles for in
those four years and here you are coming
and telling me that these vaccines i'm
going to be taking over and they were
done within 300 days 300 days brian and
part of the reason why i wrote this book
is to explain that we'll actually know
the research the the amazing american
usually but not always um technology
that went into this stuff it took years
literally decades to get it right right
so first off how long did it take for
them to realize what they were dealing
with
so some of the scientists i write about
and the executives in in the companies
like stefan bensel at moderna and uger
sahin at beyond tech in january they
were starting to get scared and there's
an executive i write about actually a
senior guy at moderna january of 2020
january 2020 he started telling his
family
pat buy stuff
toilet paper tissues he bought a third
refrigerator to stock up his house and
food and his family thought it was crazy
we're talking about the middle of
january when you and i i was flying i
remember flying in europe in the middle
of january and i wasn't wearing a mask
no one was kind of concerned but these
guys were so i give them a lot of credit
they were
worried about this this this both of
pandemic but also just about the spread
and where it might go so to their credit
they said we have to do something about
it
understood so we have to do something
about it why not go for a therapeutic to
treat it
yeah it's a good question some companies
did try uh largely unsuccessful there's
hopes now
that maybe we'll have a pill but
historically vaccines are
how we stop pandemics and how we stop
plagues things like polio
going back in history and even more
recently vaccines are usually the thing
the holy grail because you get a shot
and you're protected and vaccines what's
really fascinating to me is until 2020
the big companies really didn't want to
be in vaccines there wasn't that much
money in vaccines you know you take a
shot every once in a while it's not like
a statin every day who wants to be in it
so what i found fascinating is the big
giants merck gsk sanofi they're the
vaccine giants they didn't go after a
coveted vaccine or they did
half-heartedly they weren't successful
instead it was these unknown companies
modern or beyond tech those kinds of
scientists why do you think they did
uh partly because they're
entrepreneurial it takes sort of uh
innovators people that ignore the
experts i mean if you remember back in
early 2020 a lot of the experts said oh
yeah it's going to take years to to
develop a vaccine don't waste your time
don't believe in mrna it hasn't been
proven before and i give these guys a
lot of credit to scientists within these
companies and they believed in their
work and and they had this resilience
and an ability to ignore the experts how
many companies were actually contracted
by uh the america the u.s government to
go to work on this vaccine so operation
warp speed shows six companies to give
funding to two um from three different
vaccine approaches mrna is one the
identivirus one is is another approach
and there's a protein subunit approach
the three approaches and what they did
was was a little bit like an investment
portfolio operation warp speed said
we're gonna have a portfolio here and
we're gonna assume that some will work
some won't work we're gonna get some
home run in this portfolio they got more
than one home run and you got to give a
warp speed tremendous amount of credit
both for the financing but other kind of
help they gave the companies as well and
i don't think it's appreciated how much
um the government worked with these
companies to sit to develop these
vaccines like we've never possibly seen
before greg zuckerman here his book is
out today if you have not heard of how
this happened no one has he does
original reporting like nobody else have
ever seen he's able to unwind it for the
everyman even though greg sounds like a
scientist he's not he got a phd to help
him out and explain this whole thing to
him uh and the name of the book is
called a shot to save the world who came
up with the idea for operation warp
speed of the concept so um
it's not clear it was brought to donald
trump part of it uh mancelleslawy is was
the head of it matas lawyer he's an
interesting guy he was on the board of
modern but he was always a little bit
skeptical of modern and mrna for years
but he's a super smart guy and donald
trump got got behind the administration
got behind it it was a brilliant idea
because never in history have we done
things at the same time meaning
manufacture vaccine test the vaccine do
all the steps necessary usually you wait
and it takes years literally takes years
first you test it first you develop it
then you test it and then you
manufacture it and the idea was let's do
it all at the same time so we're losing
tens of thousands of people we don't
have that type of time so we got to go
do it so uh there's a race to do it so
how did the government set up private
industry to be successful to do their
thing to free them up to to take chances
so part of it was with plain old cash
and uh it was money that some of these
companies took not all of them but some
of them took to develop to to do trials
to develop their vaccines but it was
also money that they paid to buy the
vaccines ahead of time i mean can you
imagine the risk that was taken and the
criticism that might have resulted had
these vaccines not worked out that had
not been not been effective we as a
government stepped up we paid we wrote
big checks to these companies saying we
think you're going to get it right we
think you're going to produce these
vaccines and we're going to write a
check right now and they needed that
money they were they were desperate some
of these companies i write about were
desperate for financing and as as
recently as may 2020.
so you explained this to me and
hopefully this question will come out
right you said for the first time they
were
able to test in real time it wasn't like
hey try this you were able to test in
real time how so i would argue that the
testing um was traditional in that there
were tens of thousands of people that
undergo underwent the trials volunteers
and such they recruited them they just
went at a faster pace but not
compromising safety and i was looking
for that i was careful about that and
everyone i've talked to was saying to me
greg we were aware we were scared like
anybody else and we knew that if we
produced a vaccine that had a had an
awful side effect not only would it blow
it for us you know our company and our
effort it would blow it for everyone so
we were really very careful so to their
credit the fda moved quicker than usual
but not in terms of compromising safety
just in terms of getting rid of the
bureaucracy so when did they start
seeing success
so
some of these companies like moderna had
early signs we're talking even january
and february of 2020
in things they were testing in monkeys
and in mammals um so they internally
were pretty optimistic but
they couldn't um say no right they
couldn't say they weren't sure we
weren't they weren't a lot of these
mammals either so they had hints they
had early hints when you and i were
starting to get nervous about this uh
pandemic when i was locking down in my
basement in new jersey um these
companies were starting to get
optimistic but the real question was
would they have the resources and
moderna yes they turned to the
government but they also turn to wall
street i mean wall street gets all this
criticism big pharma gets all this
criticism we've got to give them a lot
of credit wall street stepped up at a
time in may 2020 the gates foundation
didn't give modern money
merck didn't want to work with modern a
lot of people didn't want to have
anything to do with modernism they were
unheard of unknown they're approached no
one really trusted and and wall street
did step up and after we have to give
them a lot of credit they gave over a
billion dollars put them in in the
pocket they bought shares and modernist
said go go go let's go build this
vaccine where the gate foundation put
their money then oh they made other kind
of bets and they did good work i don't
want to dismiss but they didn't go for
this yeah they they they had resources
tied up elsewhere so so to describe for
everyone uh you know if i want the flu
vaccine they shoot the flu into you and
they hope they got the right flu right
but mrna is different and this could be
very important for someone listening
right now who's very queasy about
getting a shot because they don't know
what they're shooting into their system
what should they know that's exactly
right so it's important to know that
traditionally not in not these vaccines
but traditionally vaccines shots
included as you say either a killed
version of the virus itself a
watered-down version of it tenuated it's
called so you have some version of the
vaccine and it's true of all traditional
vaccines um polio etc and historically
there was some percentage of people who
unfortunately got the disease that they
were trying to protect and the whole
idea of vaccines is to educate to teach
the immune system and so historically
say all right i'm going to put in the
vaccine a piece of the virus and the
immune system is going to have an
experience it's going to have an
education and it's going to know when it
sees it for the real time ah we know how
to fight it off with these vaccines
they're very different so mrna basically
is a message it's called
m is for messenger and we all have mrna
in us it's how our proteins that we
depend on are created basically the um
dna doesn't go into the cell goes dna to
mrna to uh creates protein that's sort
of the basics of biology and
people scientists entrepreneurs
venture capitalists always said well
okay if mrna is so important nmrna can
create naturally we're talking about
naturally creates proteins in the body
what if we could create these mrnas
these molecules in the lab and it was
always like this holy grail well yeah of
course if we could figure it out we
could create we could make the body into
its own manufacture its own um vaccine
or even drug a manufacturer in our own
body so it was always like the hope and
the skeptics always said nah there's no
way you can get mrna all the way into
the cell because it's chopped up so
quickly that's the the fascinating thing
about mrna some people are worried that
it's going to affect their dna it's
going to be
no it gets chopped up almost instantly
and that's why people never wanted to
work with mrna so it took years and
years of entrepreneurship and innovation
and stubbornness on the part of
researchers that i write about in my
book to finally figure out a way to
create mrna in the lab that's called
recombinant mrna put it in a vaccine and
get it all the way into our body and and
then it does get chopped up really
quickly by the enzymes but it lasts long
enough to teach our body to create a
protein in this case it's the spike
protein create a protein that teaches
the body's immune system ah next time i
see that spike protein i'm gonna go
fight it off so yeah modern and fish are
working for it with mrna what's johnson
johnson doing so johnson johnson and uh
this group in england oxford university
along with astrazeneca they use a virus
and they say okay we're going to put the
gene for the in this case the spike
protein onto a virus put it in a vaccine
and that virus is going to carry this
genetic information these genetic
instructions into the body's cell and
you say to yourself well wait why do i
want to put a virus into my body and the
answer is this virus is not harmful
they've taken out the ingredients such
that it doesn't spread it just gets and
viruses are really good at getting into
the cells and then it disappears so
that's their approach it's um effective
it's not quite as effective as mrna but
it's effective and um i would take the j
uh in a heartbeat so um that's another
approach i write about in my book and
it's another one that took years and
years to get right we're here to discuss
a monumental national achievement from
the instant the coronavirus invaded our
shores we raced into action to develop a
safe and effective vaccine at breakneck
speed it would normally take five years
six years seven years or even more
in order to achieve this goal we harness
the full power of government
the genius of american scientists and
the might of
american industry to save millions and
millions of lives all over the world
we're just days away from authorization
from the fda and we're pushing them hard
at which point we will immediately begin
mass distribution
before operation warp speed the typical
time frame for development that approval
as you know
could be infinity
and we were very very happy that we were
able to get things done at a level that
nobody has ever seen before and he's not
over exaggerating for one point really
president trump making the announcement
in december of 2020 they got a vaccine
they got two of them they would
eventually have three of them and might
be another one coming that is not news
to greg zuckerman along the way taking a
bet on the vaccine and taking a bet that
would be a good story greg that's you
you were betting that they were going to
get a vaccine so you were learning about
the technology behind it the science
binder the biology behind it and that
moment in december what were you
thinking oh
i was happy for the world happy for
myself and my family happy for my loved
ones um my uncle passed away of kovid i
know people with long covid um you know
we've all gone through a really
difficult period and i think we're too
close to it to to appreciate that these
vaccines and i know to some people
they're controversial but to me they're
just an american invention and american
reflection of american exceptionalism
and and genius and we don't give enough
credit to to operation war speed to the
scientists to the the financiers the
american financiers behind it it's a
real american success story so you said
the pfizer and moderna the heads are
foreign born but they said they had to
do it in america why yeah i spoke to
both of them stefan bensel he's from
marseille in france a thick accent uger
sahin
born in turkey and he lives in germany
right now and his company is germany and
yet they both told me that these
vaccines the menderna ones and the
pfizer biontech ones could not have been
produced without america without
american investors you know we forget
we've got um the ecosystem here
capitalism in this country will step up
and take risk that you can't get
anywhere else you could not do this in
europe there's no money for these kinds
of companies with no earnings with only
a hope of developing something down the
road years in advance and frankly
there's american venture capital the
american investors american stock market
and these companies and these executives
all told me greg we could not have done
this without america and we could not
have done this without the help of these
investors and in the scientists from
america are you surprised we quickly got
about 50 60 percent up we seem to be
stuck around 70 of the country getting
two shots and getting ready to go are
you surprised at some skepticism and
what would you say to skeptics listening
right now so i would say and and i try
to emphasize we're not doctors but you
you did you might as well be after this
book you just wrote yeah i i'm no doctor
whatsoever but um i talk to um
scientists and i talk to
people that are not political i really
try to emphasize people that are just
experienced and the experience the time
that the years that went into these
vaccines needs to be appreciated and and
the the remarkable effectiveness also
needs to be appreciated a shot to save
the world greg zuckerman has done it
again pick it up it's real time history
good job greg thank you bro
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now